yeah I'm working with laser technology
I'm working with photons individual
waves of laser light it's tough
sometimes when you're doing something
that everyone sees as eccentric in its
era that you sort of have to wait till
the next generation comes along who
looks at it and goes like this isn't
crazy this is amazing good-afternoon
holographic studios today we're in New
York City and we're interviewing this
guy Jason Arthur say Penn but his
friends call him dr. Laser nicknames you
don't choose them you get stuck with
them he's a holography that means he
makes Holograms and he's been doing it
for a really long time this is now 41
years but not the kind like Tupac right
oh no not even similar I mean two pecs
illusion wasn't even 3d holograms they
get kind of a bad rap but they're
actually a really advanced science
holography is a field a subdivision of
photonics that deals with wave recording
of the phone at science
long story short a hologram is made by
bouncing laser light off of a three
dimensional object and onto special film
mostly all right Holograms they've been
relevant a handful of times in the 80s
holographic jewelry in the 90s suddenly
had hogs and pokemon cards oh my god my
son was like you know very big on
getting the hologram ones there's no
denying that these things they're just
not mainstream but dr. laser doesn't
care because he loves what he does maybe
it doesn't make me famous maybe it
doesn't make me rich but it makes me
very very very happy hell yeah
you do you dr. laser
you